Are you watching a web-enabled TV while browsing
on your smartphone with your laptop nearby?
Think about unplugging!
Because you’re wasting energy, money AND
heating up the planet.
Hello everyone, tech addict Amy with you today
on DNews.
Odds are you’re watching this on a computer
or phone that you plug in but rarely, if ever,
powerdown.
Well, listen up, because perpetual “stand-by”
mode is really not a good thing!
As we become more connected and more dependent
on all the latest gadgets and appliances,
we’re inadvertently using electricity when
we don’t need to.
This includes computers that have a “sleep”
mode, DVRs that sit idle waiting to record
the next “Game of Thrones,” that silly
clock on your microwave and your plugged-in,
fully-charged laptop.
For most of these appliances, they draw power
from the mains simply because they’re plugged-in
and not because they’re doing anything useful.
In a study of Northern Californian households
carried out by the Natural Resources Defense
Council, researchers found that 23 percent
of residential energy consumption was coming
from idle devices.
On average in these homes, there were 65 such
devices.
Roughly a quarter of all energy use comes
from appliances and devices that aren’t
currently doing a thing.
This may not sound like a lot, but the study
crunched some numbers.
Assuming that the whole of the United States
has a similar addiction to useless machines
plugged into the wall, we, as a nation, consume
an extra 64 billion kilowatt-hours of electricity
per year -- that’s the equivalent power
consumption of Alabama and Arizona for 12
months!
If there were powerplants dedicated to keeping
idle devices on standby mode, we’d need
50 large (500-megawatt) stations to make that
happen.
Obviously, there’s a cost.
This excess energy use translates to approximately
19 billion dollars per year, which averages
out to about
165 dollars per US household per year.
But the cost isn’t just financial, it’s
environmental.
Idle electronics account for 44 million metric
tons of carbon dioxide emissions per year
-- that’s nearly 5 percent of carbon dioxide
generated by the US residential sector per
year.
Carbon dioxide is a powerful greenhouse gas,
so it stands to reason that if households
would just unplug their electronics while
they’re not being used, another source of
the greenhouse gas can be limited.
So unplug your devices!
Turn off your power bars!
And be be aware of how much you actually need
your computers.
Odds are, you shut a lot of things down, save
yourself some money, and help the planet.
And if you’re super keen, why not get in
on the ground floor and help develop the tech
that will help save our environment!
Tech innovations are constantly changing our
lives.
Full Sail’s Simulation & Visualization degree
program was designed to create future engineers
who will develop systems for the twenty-first
century.
All of Full Sail’s Web & Tech programs are
designed specifically to flex as new methods
and applications unfold, allowing students
to remain relevant and informed throughout
their entire academy journey.
To learn more about these programs, and all
of Full Sail’s technology degree programs,
visit fullsail.edu/DNews.
So electronics are a culprit, but what else
in our houses are damaging the environment?
Trace has the rundown in this video right
here.
So with some new knowledge, will you be changing
your device habits?
Let us know in the comments below, don’t
forget to like this video and subscribe for
a new episode of DNews every day of the week.